thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the careful boys and today we have
Chappelle back in hey
welcome back what up Chappelle hi I'm
back how you doing man I'm good how are
you guys that's very good very good
small talk we're here
for the deep [ __ ] right away
what's the deepest she got something
[ __ ] exciting some new subscribers
huh yeah let's start with tofu that's
good yeah
what's your favorite vegetarian food wow
that that's a cold question all right
that's how we start that's bar baby you
know you know Traders Trader Joe's
Trader Joe's has this uh vegan orange
chicken that I really like yeah and I'm
making Trader minks
[Laughter]
dude the orange chicken at Trader Joe's
legit wait is that the actual thing yeah
brand name
but Maine's not even close to Joe
it's not like Trader Joe's what would be
the Trader Joe's yeah
that's not even but is that Chinese it's
mean a common name well Jose and Joe is
pretty close right because you just
gotta move like the ass over yeah
McDonald's McDonald's oh what what are
we doing why are we doing this let's go
make McDonald's they even have like an
Indian one too because what's that
called
I don't know
that's not bad I know a couple patels
yeah some of them come on the Shelf
very cultured I mean like chicken made
out of
when you're like to go vegetarian
especially modern day vegetarian where
you're like I'll substitute real food
for I don't know what the [ __ ] you know
it is it is interesting it's interesting
interesting thing I try not to eat that
stuff too much because I mean you're not
you're not really supposed to so I try
to keep it you know that's why I stay
more along the lines so the idea of like
switching that diet is like I'm not
supposed to eat this so let me eat stuff
that I'm not supposed to which is weird
like like you know like sometimes I want
to punch these vegans and vegetarians
for this dumb [ __ ] it's like hey like
you you talking about not eating meat
but what what is this [ __ ] you know so
like not like this [ __ ] oh you know I
don't you I [ __ ] with animal rights I do
yeah heavy okay heavy yeah you better
quote me on that but it is interesting
to sit here and it's like what's this
fake [ __ ] yeah what is that and then
they call it plant-based like a wood
plant yeah
uh nuclear power plant
dog so how do you feel about like the
lab grown meat stuff like the impossible
meal right yeah are you have you ever
tried a burger is that yeah vegetarian
if you didn't have to kill an animal to
eat it yeah lab grown steak is that
vegetarian oh oh yeah that's the new
thing right yeah you know actually I'm
not I'm not familiar with that World
um I'm new to that world but but it is
interesting yeah I mean I don't know I
don't know how long have you been
vegetarian a year oh no it'd be a year
in April sorry oh well what um what
caused a decision you're not committed
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
for me I'm like I ran away from that
world so then for people that want to go
there I'm like why you know what's
interesting as well is a lot of uh
religions they do it they do it that's
why I ran away from it that table over
there David I mean part two yeah yeah I
learned about kosher you guys know what
kosher is yeah you know like the front
of the atom right right you don't eat
like the no so I well I think that but
also they they kill their own animals
but you have to I think there's
something with you have to prey on it
well it has to die immediately has to be
an instant kill If It suffers then you
can't eat it oh yeah yeah yeah that's
like who defines the suffering part well
if it's like
headshots
but if it's like boom
headshots it was like a headshot that's
it do you guys follow any of those
hardcore nature Pages absolutely
Nature's metal I didn't realize how
[ __ ] [ __ ] some animals are you can
see a buff ass [ __ ] like Buck or some
[ __ ] right and you're like when you see
that guy on the force like this guy will
run me over yeah and then you see like a
[ __ ] lion like bite that like bite my
tail like this I did they just go oh
you act like it's us biting it like a
lion's bite it's like it's not even
bleeding it it's like barely Nick and
I'm like that still you you call the bug
[ __ ] and you said a lion was it's fun
yeah
a food chain chop the whole leg if it
chopped the whole leg then you could get
it squealed but it barely bits some
hairs the bit some hairs and you just
see the [ __ ] like give up like
oh vegetarian people yeah it ain't gonna
do anything bad is it run away you don't
even got claws
I swear to God it's like a like barely
missed them and this full like he just
like rolls over and then now this guy he
can still move you still see him
blinking and [ __ ] and although lying is
just having its way you know let's bring
a lion in here
I just thought this got another Buck
[ __ ] go head to head five times to
try to [ __ ] the other [ __ ] female
buck and then you you couldn't do that
at the lion but one tail bite yeah
that's how you act here's the thing
here's the thing about lions lions lions
attack from the back yeah
they will go for this so they will go
for this yeah they'll go yeah
they want to suffocate you yeah it's
worse to get from a hyena pack hyena
packs go from an [ __ ] yep they
literally go from the [ __ ] and eat
you out they don't let you die they just
they just like they want it fresh yeah
they want it fresh yeah not not Kosher
you see they caught that uh that
mountain lion
he ate like two dogs or something like
that yeah he's a big [ __ ] that's
pretty big yeah and you see somebody's
yard you see some of these coyotes dude
some of these coyotas are [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] kind of like German Shepherds they
kill dogs like crazy I'm saying that's
why we gotta get rid of the coyote the
coyotes dude we gotta get rid of them
you know in the South that you can hunt
those year round really I'm gonna go wow
[Laughter]
Revenge
there was a video of a coyote trying to
snatch up a two-year-old have you seen
that on someone no I'm coming after your
kids bro we gotta get rid of them
what was they were the parents where are
the parents they were loading up the van
you know what I mean that was the video
and then it was just broad daylight what
was it I have no idea you don't know
probably like Coyote Hills yeah like
there's coyotes like in every state
they're rampant they're not they're not
that big dude the Reese I feel like in
the past couple years they got big some
dogs are bigger than girls yeah like a
Great Dane oh great dane is way bigger
than yeah for sure yeah but a Great Dane
is like are they gonna be killing other
dogs health problems on the way I know
right yeah yeah I'm gonna walk
downstairs
a pit bull mate Rottweiler pit bulls or
yeah oh like if you had like a gangster
ass Pitbull
we need to test our Theory
[Laughter]
no lie if you were if you were like in
another if you were in another country
where like you know it's not we're
tourists it's not our rules and it was
like dog fights would you watch it you
mean like when it Rome do you want to
watch a dog okay but coyote and dog I
want to see which one beats the coyote
we were depend on what kind of dog yeah
that's like science that's not
entertainment that's like science yeah
we were in Hawaii and we saw these
chickens around and I was like and in my
head I was like yo I think I'd watch a
[ __ ] fight you would and then you'd
watch chickens fight afterwards yeah
yeah yeah you dirty man
like not razors on there yeah wait
really yeah I don't think I could watch
how long have you guys been doing that
y'all seem to know a lot
yeah they like armed them with like
knives and [ __ ] on the closet all those
cops got killed by the uh chickens that
one time they broke up the cockfight
yeah they broke up they started coming
up to the cops cops and slicing them up
because
sisters on himself he gets your like
vital veins or whatever in your leg Yeah
I think a cop died getting sliced on a
vein yeah listening or something like it
sliced them in the artery and I think it
was like infected and I think he died
like the day off whoa that is a terrible
one you just blasted that [ __ ]
his Tombstone says death by cops
I'm also down to see a rooster get
electrocuted by or tased by a cop too
wait how'd you get there
at the beginning of the video it's also
good for animal rights [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I'm down
seriously well because we gotta save the
cop's life he's already dead nope yeah
yeah find that [ __ ] they should
have had some tasers and shot it shot it
at them and you should have seen a
[ __ ] rooster going like this turn
into the fried chicken
that's so sad all battered as my as a
vegetarian I can't believe you said that
I can't believe you said those words
wait so what was your uh motivation to
become vegetarian like what I mean
honestly I don't really [ __ ] with me
like that we're gonna leave occasionally
chickens vegetarian conversations
exciting yeah excuse yeah and that's
fine you never liked the taste of meat I
mean I I never [ __ ] with I never
[ __ ] with steak I never [ __ ] with
like I mean I I eat a burger yeah but
like I'm trying to you know the one
thing I do miss chicken tenders bacon
why you say chicken tenders because
because I'll say this wait wait wait
wait wait wait
[Applause]
he said Raising Cane
that has nothing to do with what you're
insinuating
the fried one I have a question to ask
the group Colonel don't you
know
you
ought to roll dude our chicken tenders
not the most unanimously liked food
nuggets and then at the very last what's
the difference between nugget and tender
come on man it's not ten it's not racism
how about that racism it's not what else
you got but it's still pretty good
chicken tenders put yourself out of this
chicken tenders are not four kids though
it was a purple drink with that man
I didn't say that Anthony will you talk
I swear to God I did it don't ruin his
whole bit
that's coming later you got a grape soda
coming up yeah you just wait for later
in the day Chapel yeah but I was at this
conversation with like other people and
I was saying like chicken tenders are so
unanimously like okay everybody all kids
menus dude chicken across adults bro it
doesn't matter what kind of 35. you
don't like chicken you don't like
chicken you know I'm not a kid you see
him he's trying to think of something
years old and I love chicken but you
didn't answer the question I was gonna
say bacon
that's another one that's another hotel
favorite
try me yeah you don't like uh vegetarian
bacon is pretty good though isn't it
yeah that's not too bad yeah it's
actually not bad yeah sometimes I
actually like it a little bit whatever
yeah you guys were vegetarians for how
long pescatarian vegetarian our our
cult-like religion says you can kind of
eat beef but if you do you're kind of
wrong oh really yeah there was like a
very passive aggressive yeah
in the school and the church they never
served any meat no one yeah but you
could do it you could eat it at home
yeah but like if you were in school
school yeah
event is like Venice Beach
yo I never heard that before
you're right chicken tenders is the
right answer
right all right all these years I've
never heard that that's the [ __ ]
funny if they have Venice Beach
yeah this is our literally free
it's like a it's kind of similar to what
Jewish people believe plus Jesus
Saturday is a day of worship so we go to
church on Saturday instead of Sunday
and then Sunday you're not you're not
allowed to do anything right uh Saturday
you're not allowed that's the Saturday
they took everything that's Judaism and
then put it on steroids yeah with a
profit it's like Old Testament this
religion been around uh Seven Days Seven
hundreds something like that oh it goes
it goes pretty far back but it's kind of
it's kind of considered by Deep
considering like I don't know like
religion
that's kind of why it sort of consists
New Wave yeah yeah that's not that's
that new [ __ ] like yeah
I thought it was a white label yeah
Mormons Jehovah Witness whatever it
might be the trigger Mings of religion
but I know we're all Asian really yeah
yeah a lot of SDA people are there's a
lot of Asians
yeah George pink dick George from um but
he married to an Asian woman though
let's start with pink dick yeah right
that's what they call them pink dick
George because he's so have you seen his
dick is Dick's probably pink you ever
seen his dick no I haven't seen him wow
dude he hasn't seen Georgia you get a
rep like that
George Kimmel dude yeah George Kimball's
west side
of Venice that just sounds like it's
like super raw all the time that doesn't
sound painful whites are different
they're always like a lab rat pink I
think oh God yeah we were just talking
about like is it like lab grown like you
would eat it like what yeah no that's
too much dude no yeah I wouldn't suck on
yeah have you guys ever had ice cream
that didn't have dairy or sugar in it
yeah yeah no sugar yeah yeah because
like the church they would have this ice
cream and it had no Dairy and no sugar
what did it taste like it takes it
tastes like straight up Vicks is it just
oh God yo shout out to fix if you ever
lie I don't know it was Menthol yeah
men Menthol ice cream
but you know what though they're doing
something right because um have you
heard of a blue Zone it's blue zones are
areas that have the most centennials or
people that live the longest right so
there's Okinawa there's like some parts
of green Joe's bragging again dude and
then
oh centenarians so like in Loma Linda
it's like uh it's like you know how the
Mormons got Salt Lake City yeah
seven-day Adventists have the Loma Linda
all right so then in that area is a Blue
Zone because of their diet
really so vegetarianism might be working
well for them where's the shame
associated with it
specifically shame yo did you see that
one uh docu series on Netflix uh keeps
keep sweet the one about the uh LGs
it was but it was a different it was a
sub genre of LDS yeah I thought Loma
Linda was an LDS area no it's that's
Seventh-day Adventist what's the
difference between SDA and LDS Latter
Day Latter Day Saints
you think they fight each other yeah
right yeah
it sounds kind of hard right that's
pretty tight well you know what we got
one of those crazy offshoot ones too and
then they did Waco yeah they were the
Waco people the crash is a offshoot of
SDA so they got more street cred then
he's an SDA that went off the rails yeah
yeah that's what happened with this more
this uh also the same thing huh oh [ __ ]
LDS got marvelous dude [ __ ] everybody
we got like militant and stuff yeah they
they do because they believe in uh
polygamy so they had multiple wives and
they didn't care what age their wives
was wow oh a little slippers
live no right right I'd say younger
80s the upside
it's gonna be optimistic yeah
nobody's trying to say it yeah right
yeah you think 90 year old women having
babies I don't know you know because
they because they they breed them and
they have like a lot of colony and stuff
they had a little Colony man and homie
homie was like Reckless where was this
colony
uh some part of uh Utah yeah oh and it
was in Utah yeah it's a crazy Doc and
then he had he had a um somewhere in
Texas too in Texas is when people were
like who who the [ __ ] is this guy oh
that's when they start questioning [ __ ]
and then because Texans don't [ __ ]
around yeah we all [ __ ] like everybody
and we have 10 wives yeah yeah exactly
that's how they roll you know so how
many like documentaries got to come out
on Netflix before like a religion get
canceled you know what I mean I know
that religion still exists what yeah
could they the homies locked up for like
life and they still go visit them like
people like still believe he's the
prophet or something yeah all the 90
year old wives will visit him yeah they
believe in his [ __ ] hey I feel like
religions don't get canceled though they
don't they don't how are you gonna How
You Gonna Cancel a religion yeah what
are you gonna do my God and Jesus yeah
you can't cancel all that does is test
their faith yeah
damn yeah because even Nazis aren't
canceled right
right
recruitment High yes they got they got
2.0 they got the NEOS the Neo knots
all over South America too yeah they've
been improving you sounded like you
about to sign up or something I know
right yeah I'm excited
they refresh their website
they're following their link trees
foreign
[Music]
[Music]